with Studio consolidation and cinematic
universe has been the name of the game
in Hollywood today filmmakers are more
eager than ever to bring fan favorites
together and you might be surprised by
some of the cinematic clashes
potentially coming to a theater near you
likely intrigued by the blockbuster
success of live-action movies inspired
by 80s cartoons like transformers
Paramount Pictures announced in 2015 its
intention to create a sprawling multi
film world featuring a number of 80s
cartoons including GI Joe micro nuts
visionaries and masks all those cartoons
were built around toy lines and they're
all controlled by toy conglomerates
Hasbro now so one could call this the
Hasbro Cinematic Universe
Hasbro's moviemaking wing or spark
pictures will make the movies and
Paramount will oversee development Oscar
winner Akiva Goldsman has been linked to
this multi movie plan that's compared to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but with
five years gone without a movie
featuring the holographic visionaries or
transforming vehicles of masks it could
be that this crossover attempt has faced
difficulties getting off the ground when
Paramount announces plans for a series
of movies based on several lines of
Hasbro owned 80s toys its didn't yet
control the rights to one of the most
popular merchandising juggernauts of the
90s The Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
from 1993 on the Power Rangers franchise
rebooted almost every year but generally
always start a group of teens who each
controlled a giant robot which would
combine to create an even larger robots
which said used to fight off evil aliens
and monsters yeah the Power Rangers are
in the hasbro family and rumor has it
that hasbro plans on combining the
property with another asset the
transformers according to a supposed
insider in contact with comic book movie
comm journalist Mikey Sutton in
September 2019 hasbro once both
franchises to inhabit the same universe
however this would not be the Michael
Bay transformers but rather the vision
set forth by the 2018 transformers
spin-off a bumblebee Marvel sold the
x-men film rights to the studio formerly
known as 20th Century Fox in the late
90s with old
in a successful franchise but doesn't
movies over two decades but that deal
predates the development of Marvel
Studios and the Paramount and eventually
Disney which created the vast and
sweeping Marvel Cinematic Universe the
possibility of a crossover film
featuring the Avengers and x-men became
substantially more likely in 2019
after Marvel's parent company Disney
purchased Fox and his properties for
more than seventy billion dollars
according to a source who spoke to we
got this covered in August 20 19 mar 14
2013 14 lead-up to a movie featuring
both teams should we have nametags
well I'm spider-man and this is my
trusty sidekick Wolverine don't push him
Sony bought the film rights to
spider-man and associated characters
years before Marvel started making their
own movies and subsequently made a hit
trilogy starring Tobey Maguire and then
two mixed bag adventures with Andrew
Garfield by the time Sony rebooted the
franchise again with spider-man
homecoming starring Tom Holland the
Marvel Cinematic Universe have launched
and Disney and Marvel had to carefully
work out a deal with Sony to feature
Spidey a Marvel Comics creation in those
movies in 2019 the rival Studios worked
out an arrangement they had co-financed
one more MCU based by demand movie with
Holland and then the sole rights would
go back to Sony but Sony still controls
the film rights to more than 900 Marvel
heroes and they've been developing what
they call Sony's universe of Marvel
characters included in that 2018 s
blockbuster hit venom an origin story
for a Peter Parker foe Tom Hardy starred
as alien symbiote possessed reporter
Eddie Brock aka venom with both
spider-man and one of the franchise's
most popular villains and it's stable
Sony would certainly consider pairing
them up in a crossover movie the success
of Marvel and DC movies led Studios to
explore the cinematic possibilities of
characters from other lesser-known
houses that's why Sony has designs on a
cinematic series featuring properties
from valiant entertainments first up is
a Studios 2020 adaptation of bloodshot
starring Vin Diesel as a scientifically
enhanced indestructible superhero and
the control of a shady corporation
planter emplaced a compliment bloodshot
with harbinger a tale about teenage
superheroes fighting against an evil
organization seeking to exploit their
abilities to bloodshot movies and to
harbinger installments would then lead
into an Avenger style crossover epic
called harbinger Wars featuring
characters from both worlds and based on
the valiant series published in 2013 but
by 2019 the possibility of a Balian
universe seemed unlikely due to the
complicating issues of Rights
Sony kept the rights to blood shots but
passed Harbinger over to Paramount
they're two of the most iconic and
influential franchises in fantasy
fiction in both book and movie form l
frank Baum's story set in the merry old
Land of Oz and there is Carroll's
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland Baum
wrote more than a dozen Oz books between
1900 and 1920 while Carroll's Wonderland
adventures appeared in the 19th century
and are so perennial II beloved that
they've been adapted for the screen
hundreds of times in 2017 netflix
acquired a script called Dorothy and
Alice written by a California teacher
named Justin MERS in which Dorothy is
sent to a home for emotionally troubled
children where she meets Alice both fear
for the fantasy lands are in danger in
2019 screenwriter and a Klausen
announced that she been hired to rewrite
the script which could be the first of
several Netflix original films teaming
up the classic heroines white a director
Quentin Tarantino is interested in Zorro
a character who jumped off the pages of
early 20th century pop paperbacks to
take his vigilante heroics and 1800
Spanish California to the formulaic
cinema of the 1920s and 1930s in 2013 a
Tarantino collaborating with Matt Wagner
co-wrote a django Zorro a sequel to
Django Unchained in the form of a seven
issue comic book miniseries that finds a
bounty hunter portrayed by Jamie Foxx
going to work as a bodyguard for the
masked and mysterious Zorro
this print crossover is in the process
of becoming a film crossover - Tarantino
brought some comedian jerod Carmichael
to help him craft a screenplay based on
the comic series it's unclear if
Tarantino would direct the eventual
Django Zoram
Vee cuz he's promised to retire after
his tenth film not only is there a new
epic monster movie battle of the ages
crossover coming up but it also marks
the completion of a trilogy after
rampaging through the world and
destroying life and property in 2014's
Godzilla and 2019 s Godzilla king of the
monsters the titular green kaiju will
once again wreak havoc in Godzilla vs.
Kong it's a throwback to the classic
Japanese made Godzilla movies in which
the big guy fought against all kinds of
other gigantic mutant monsters such as a
butterfly like Mothra and bird thing
Rodin and war those creatures have
appeared in recent installments of
legendary pictures monster vers Godzilla
king of the monsters will mark the first
time since 1962 s King Kong vs. Godzilla
that the two most famous movie monsters
will officially wage war against each
other check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]